- "Just landed, LA, like
first stop, In-N-Out,
Animal Style, crazy time
something wrapped in"...
Like, I don't know what
any of these things are.
(upbeat music)
- It's kind of like the west coast
staple fast food restaurant, right?
- I have not had the
secret menu at In-N-Out.
Someone told me about it, it
didn't sound that appealing.
- The secret menu...
I don't know how secret it is.
(upbeat music)
- What? (laughs)
- So, there's no bun
with the Flying Dutchman?
- I see nothing Dutch
nor flying about this.
- Yeah, I don't think it
looks like a burger at all.
- Looks like a smiley face.
- Yeah, it's like a grilled
cheese made of meat.
- Mmm...
- It is just like an
incomplete experience.
- You're supposed to have a bun and stuff.
- I might order it with a salad.
Do they have salads there?
(upbeat music)
- Oh, it's lettuce.
- I feel like the point of a bun
is to sort of hold everything together,
and I'm not sure this
lettuce is doing a good job.
- You would think Protein Style would mean
more protein, maybe?
Like chicken breasts as the bun.
- It's like a giant
salad that you can hold
and it's filled with meat.
That sounds good.
- I feel like anything tastes good
if you put enough Thousand
Island dressing on it.
- This is good, I like this.
I would go for this.
I'm gonna eat more.
(upbeat music)
- Okay, I feel like this is
the one that I've heard about.
- I don't know what that...
What it means.
- This one has a bun,
which is comforting to me.
- No, I don't...
I still don't know what it means. (laughs)
- Honestly, it doesn't
taste that different to me.
Tastes pretty regular, guys.
(upbeat music)
- It's not like meat style.
It's not covered in animal.
- It's like a salty, cheesy good time.
- Mhmmm, okay, I like
it, mhmmm, I like this.
(upbeat music)
- This has got to be a joke
because this is just a burger
without a patty, right?
- So, there's...
It doesn't look bad,
it just doesn't look
like a grilled cheese.
- I feel
like you could do a way better job
making a grilled cheese at your house.
- It just makes me feel sad.
It's like they forgot the burger.
- I don't know.
Alright, it's also good.
(upbeat music)
- Ooh, love dessert.
- Oh, ho, ho, ho.
- I hate cold things.
(laughs)
- This is, again, really just like...
It's not so secret,
it's more of just like
a thing of convenience.
Just put all three kinds in one cup.
There you go, secret menu.
(upbeat music)
- I don't know.
- It's a charming little menu.
- You liked it so far this way,
here's more stuff on top of it.
- The secret seems to be that
they thought of all this stuff
and it's not good enough
to be on the real menu,
so it's just like, there's a secret menu.
- The Secret is a book that Oprah found
and she became obsessed with it
and told everybody it
would change their lives.
Or it's just probably a lot more sauce.